ja mich haben die Bilder beeindruckt und
ich hatte sozusagen einen schon mal
gesehen ein DejaVu von Flüchtlingen die
in Dresden ankommen von immer mehr
Flüchtlingen die in Deutschland ankommen
von immer mehr Flüchtlingen die die
Balkanroute nutzen um auch in Österreich
anzukommen um in Bayern anzukommen es
sind jetzt schon wieder zahlen die fatal
an die erste Phase von dem erinnern was
wir als 2015 im Kopf haben und das
besorgt mich neben dem ganzen
Kriegsgeschehen über das war auch hier
diskutiert haben schon sehr weil ich
glaube wenn wir das als Gesellschaft und
als Politik komplett übersehen oder wie
es bei dem Thema Zuwanderung unsere
unser Fable ist in Deutschland es zu
tabuisieren wenn wir also nicht darüber
sprechen dass jetzt schon wieder
tausende kommen es ist die Rede davon
dass in diesem Jahr womöglich 200.000
Menschen über die Balkanroute nach
Deutschland kommen können die ja dann in
unserem Sozialsystem sozusagen ihre
Zukunft finden also in die Sozialkassen
ändern dann gibt es einen ganz brutalen
Unterschied zwischen 2015 war schon
schlimm genug war und heute heute ist es
ein anderes Deutschland die Vorstellung
dass
Rentnerinnen und Rentner zu Hause
frieren dass Familien die über zwei
kleinere Einkommen verfügen sich ihre
Stromrechnungen nicht mehr leisten
können dass wir aber Flüchtlingsheime
heizen in denen illegal Eingewanderte
Menschen sitzen die in Deutschland
nichts zu suchen haben weil sie kein
Asylrecht haben ist für mich das
Zündhölzchen an einer Lunte von sozialem
Sprengstoff von Unbekannten Ausmaß und
deshalb ist meine Forderung an die
Politik hinzugucken es ist meine
Forderung an die Medien hinzugehen wenn
man nämlich hingeht sieht man es sind
wieder jüngere Männer viele jüngere
Männer und schon muss man sagen das wird
die Kriminalstatistik betreffen das wird
unsere Sozialkassen betreffen ich habe
noch mal nachgeguckt ungefähr 20
Milliarden Euro kostet das asylgeben in
Deutschland unseren Staat also uns ihr
und mein Geld
das alles ist so toxisch so giftig so
gefährlich in dieser Debatte ein lautes
auch das noch dass ich mir sagen mache
dass hier tatsächlich etwas
auseinanderdriften kann an die Ränder
was man sich in dieser Weise gar nicht
vorstellen konnte Frau Petri wenn die
Flüchtlingsströme so weitergehen ist die
AFD dann bald bei 25%
ich folge Klaus Strunz insoweit dass ich
sage in der Tat die Balkanroute wieder
als flüchtlingsroute aus Mittleren Osten
wir hören es auf Afghanistan sich
weiterhin viele Menschen aus dem Weg
machen aus anderen arabischen Ländern
das ist in der Tat die Fortsetzung von
2015 und wir haben natürlich immer so
ein bisschen bei der medialen
Betrachtung das Problem
das News die eigentlich News sind als
solche gar nicht mehr erkannt werden
weil wir die Bilder schon so oft gesehen
haben und Bilder die wir oft gesehen
haben blenden wir als Menschen einfach
aus weil wir sie vergessen wollen weil
wir sie über sind weil wir gesättigt
sind man muss davon unterscheiden dass
halte ich auch für wichtig das Thema
Ukraine Flüchtlinge und je nachdem wie
lange dieser Krieg noch dauert denn Herr
bloss ihre Vision dass ich das ist
schnell vorbei sein muss falls ja
wünschenswert wäre ist unter Umständen
gar nicht realistisch auch
überspitzt gesagt gute und schlechte
Flüchtlinge die aus der Ukraine sind die
guten die woanders herkommen sind die
schlechten ja es gibt flüchtlings- und
illegale Migranten ich habe ja als ich
noch politisch aktiv war darum gekämpft
dass wir wirklich politisch anfangen
zwischen Menschens differenzieren die
tatsächlich nur für eine Übergangszeit
in Deutschland Zuflucht brauchen und die
die einfach illegal in unsere
Sozialsysteme einwandern das ist
politisch immer bekämpft worden auch
gerade von von den Grünen und von allen
linken Parteien die eine Kategorisierung
nicht vornehmen wollen und das bis heute
nicht tun denn wir wissen ja auch dass
selbst über die Ukraine Menschen nach
Deutschland gekommen sind die keine
Ukrainer waren die aber schnell
ukrainischen Pass bekommen konnten
insofern sehe ich auf der einen Seite
das was sie auch sehen an der Strunz
dass die Entwicklung in der Tat auf ein
anderes Europa auch trifft auf ein
Europa das langsam keine Kapazitäten
mehr hat also wir drohen auch
sozialtechnisch Stück für Stück auf
einen Stand abzurutschen indem wir nicht
mehr helfen können da ist doch Luft nach
unten aber die Frage ist ja wollen wir
diesen Weg weiter beschreiten aber auch
die Notwendigkeit zu sagen Flüchtlinge
aus dem Ukraine Krieg die müssen anders
behandelt werden da muss differenziert
werden und ich dann vielleicht nur eins
mir ist ganz wichtig ich mache das nicht
den Menschen die auf der
also oder richtig also wenn ich hören
würde irgendwo auf der Welt dass es ein
Start gibt ein Land gibt wo man nur drin
sein muss dann muss man nie mehr weg man
kommt auch nie mehr weg und hat mehr
Geld als die Menschen in dem Land die
Arbeiten gehen da würde ich ja alles
packen und bloß hin also ich mache
keinen vor und ich mache den Vorwurf der
Dämlichkeit derer die damit riskieren
dass all das was uns wichtig ist er
verloren geht und ich fordere wirklich
alle auf dass auch als eine Art
Verteidigung zu sehen eines Systems dass
wir gut und richtig finden denn wenn
dieses System kollabiert es ist Weg
auf die Frage geht sogar an sie aber ein
Gedanke dazu noch es gibt ja auch
studienstatistiken die sagen dass wir
400.000 Einwanderer eigentlich pro Jahr
brauchen als Land als Deutschland
Zuwanderung die Wahrheit ist andere
natürlich
die Frage an Sie Deutschland vielleicht
einfach zu blöd für die Integration also
ich glaube man muss tatsächlich da sehr
stark unterscheiden weil auf der einen
Seite
illegale Migration muss gestoppt werden
genau also das ist das volle Zustimmung
anders zu unterstellen aber andere nur
noch ein Programm also illegale
Migration muss klar gestoppt werden über
einige Folgen und Auswirkungen haben wir
eben gesprochen trotzdem darf man einen
Punkt auch nicht ausblenden nämlich dass
wir angesichts der immer älter werdenden
Bevölkerung natürlich auch Zuwanderung
brauchen wir brauchen nur die richtigen
in Deutschland also die Fachkräfte wir
brauchen mit wir haben mittlerweile ein
Arbeitskräftemangel also es sieht man ja
häufig wenn man vor Restaurant steht vor
Bar steht vor im Friseursalon steht ne
da steht dann entweder Mitarbeiter
gesucht oder sogar manchmal heute
geschlossen wegen Personalmangel und wir
brauchen deswegen die richtigen Leute
und das ist eine nicht ganz so einfache
Aufgabe weil wir natürlich gesetzlich
erschaffen müssen dazu differenzieren
und zu sagen wir brauchen beispielsweise
ein Punktesystem und gewisse Standards
dass die richtigen zu uns kommen können
die wir dringend benötigen auf der
anderen Seite müssen wir aber auch klar
sagen diejenigen die einfach nur in die
Sozialsysteme einwandern wollen die ihn
da müssen wir ein Stoppschild auf aber
wir haben doch schon längst die Tür
zugeschlagen für richtige Fachkräfte ich
sehe es ja Mittelstand jeden Tag in
meiner Arbeit beim beim
mittelstandsverband wir diskutieren die
Fachkräfte Situation dann ist es klar
man braucht da wirklich sehr gut
ausgebildete Leute der Mittelstand ist
keine fließbandbude wo ein riesen Fabrik
ist so alles wieder Fließband da musst
du was können sonst brauchst du da gar
nicht anfangen so und jetzt ist der Witz
aber dass Leute die was können auch
rechnen können und die können natürlich
rechnen dass sie hier in dem Land eine
Menge arbeiten uns alte deutschen unsere
alten deutschen bezahlen und dann selber
nichts haben werden deswegen gehen die
in Länder wo die mehr für sich haben an
ihrem Geld es ist die Steuern
nicht sie sagen also die guten kommen
gar nicht mehr Deutschland ist kein
Zuwanderungsland der ersten Klasse mehr
für ausgebildete Fachkräfte
abwanderungsland wir haben
netto-fachkräfte Verluste so und
deswegen glaube ich dass man in der
ganzen Gesetzgebung neu aufbauen muss in
der Sozialgesetzgebung das kam ja heute
schon jetzt in der eingangsthese ist es
dringend notwendig zu überlegen dass man
also mindest Einzahl dauern irgendwas in
der Arten festlegen muss dass auch nicht
wieder in diesen Bezug kommt und wir
haben eine skandinavischen Ländern
gesehen die haben das alle durch
exerziert Dänemark gespielt andere
Norwegen ist ganz klar die haben gesagt
natürlich muss man Menschen in Not
helfen die kriegen auch was zu essen und
werden warm untergebracht das ist heute
schon viel und das muss reichen und das
ist eben nicht so dass man hier einfach
jahrelang mit zwei drei Frauen und zehn
Kindern im Haus leben kann und andere
Ehepaare deutsche Ehepaare verzichten
auf das zweite Kind weil sie sich nicht
leisten